chào các
bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn các
cái thao tác với đối tượng hình ảnh bao
gồm các thao tác như là chèn hình vào
Sau đó chúng ta sẽ định dạng và đặt vị
trí hình như thế nào cho nó phù hợp
trong vò bản của mình và bây giờ thao
tác đầu tiên là chúng ta sẽ thực hiện đó
là chèn hình ảnh vào văn bản chúng ta
đặt con trỏ tại vị trí Cần chèn chúng ta
vào thẻ
Insert chọn
picture và trong cái mục picture Insert
picture này nó có ba cái lệnh là Z
device stock email và online picture thì
Z device là chúng ta sẽ chèn cái hình
trên máy của mình s emil là chèn trên
cái thư viện của Microsoft và online
picture là
chèn những cái hình trên internet thì
thông thường nhất là chúng ta sẽ chọn là
Z device là chúng ta sẽ chèn trên cái
thiết bị của mình máy của mình Chúng ta
nhập vào
và chúng ta tìm đến cái folder mà chứa
hình Ví dụ ở đây mình tìm đến cái ổ đĩa
D và folder picture của mình và chúng ta
có thể chèn hình nhắp chuột vào hình và
chọn Insert Tuy nhiên để chèn nhiều hình
cùng lúc thì chúng ta Nhấn và giữ Ctrl
sau đó lần lượt nhắc chuột vào các cái
hình cần chèn và chúng ta chọn Insert ở
đây là mình cần chèn hai cái hình thì
chúng ta chọn luôn hai hình chúng ta
nhấn nhớ là Nhấn và giữ control sau đó
lần lượt nhấp chuột vào các cái hình cần
chọn chúng ta chọn Insert chúng ta chèn
hình vào đấy thì chúng ta có được hai
hình Vấn đề bây giờ là chúng ta sẽ thực
hiện cái thao tác
là Định dạng vị trí cho nó thay đổi kích
cỡ và Định dạng vị trí thì thứ nhất là
chúng ta sẽ
à Thay đổi kích cợ chúng ta nhấp chuột
vào các cái hình tròn bao quanh hình á
chúng ta kéo thì chúng chúng ta sẽ thay
đổi kích cỡ của hình được
đấy và thao tác quan trọng nhất sau khi
chúng ta chèn hình vào đó là Định dạng
vị trí à chúng ta quan sát rằng là khi
chúng ta chèn hình vào thì hình bao giờ
nó đánh dạc văn bản ra dạng như thế này
nó không nằm chung vào như ở bên trái
màn hình được và chúng ta rất khó thao
tác là thay đổi vị trí của nó bây giờ để
đơn giản cái thao tác và chúng ta có thể
đặt cái hình ở bất cứ vị trí nào trong
văn bản thì chúng ta bắt đầu thực hiện
gọi thao tác gọi là Định dạng vị trí
chúng ta nhấp vào hình bên phải có cái
nút này gọi là layout option chúng ta
nhắp chột vào và có những cái Định dạng
vị trí như thế này Square hay là time
hay là throw vân vân thì hai cái Tho tạo
Định dạng vị trí mà hay dùng nhất đó là
Square và b test đơn giản Square là nó n
có thể nằm chung được với văn bản B test
nó nằm sau văn bản bây giờ chúng ta chọn
Square nha nhấp đây và sau khi định dạng
Square chúng ta dễ dàng di chuyển hình
ảnh và đặt vào vị trí như ở bên bên phải
như phi mẫu rồi tương tự cái hình ảnh
cốt Kim này cũng vậy chúng ta muốn là
đặt vào vị trí bất kỳ và dễ dàng thao
tác thì chúng ta chọn layout option và
chúng ta chọn Square
nhấp rồi sau đó chúng ta di chuyển đặt
nó vào vị trí mong
muốn và lúc này chúng ta cũng dễ dàng
thao tác là thay đổi kích cỡ của
nó đó là thao tác là Định dạng vị trí
các bạn đặc biệt lưu ý cái thao tác này
nha chèn hình xong bao giờ cũng phải
Định dạng vị
trí tiếp tục là chúng ta sẽ thực hiện
thao tác là định dạng cái Style cho cái
hình này cho cái hình ảnh thì chúng ta
sẽ chọn đối tượng hình ảnh chúng ta vào
picture format và có cái mục đây picture
size chúng ta nhắp chuột vào nút này đây
Quick size nhắp chột vào và như cái hình
này thì ở file minh họa thì nó sẽ dùng
cái size có rất nhiều size sẽ dùng Style
này nhắp đây chúng ta quan sát nó giống
như bên này nha tương tự như vậy cái
hình Thứ hai này Vậy chúng ta cũng có
thể dùng cái style cho nó Quick style
cho nó đây có thể dùng kiểu này kiểu nào
đó Tùy mình mình thích dùng kiểu nào
mình dùng được chưa ở đây cái hình này
mình sẽ không định dạng sty cho nó mình
để
ý đó là thao tác là định dạng kiểu hình
size à thao tác thứ tiếp theo đó là
chúng ta có thể cắt cái hình này bớt ví
dụ đây cái hình thứ hai là Cúc đầy Đoa
này chúng ta có thể cắt xén nó bớt thì
chúng ta sẽ vào
chọn hình vào picture format chúng ta
chọn lệnh Crop
nhấp và sau đó chúng ta có thể cắt hình
trõ Vào các cái vị trí ở các cái góc
hoặc ở trên bên phải trái bên phải ở
dưới chúng ta xé hình ví dụ đây chúng ta
nhấp kéo này kéo ngược lên đó nó xé bớ
cái hình ch của mình nhắp kéo xong nhắp
vào một vị trí ở bên ngoài văn bản để
kết thúc cái việc là xé cái hình đấy Đó
là thao tác xé
hình
à thao tác tiếp theo đó là chúng ta chọn
cái cái hiệu ứng cho cái đối tượng hình
ảnh chúng ta nhấp vào đối tượng hình ảnh
chúng ta chọn picture format và chúng ta
chọn picture
ex X là hiệu ứng chúng ta nhắp chột vào
à có nhiều nhóm hiệu ứng khác nhau
à có nhiều nhóm chúng ta trình bày theo
kiểu nào thì tùy mình và bây giờ ví dụ
như chúng ta chọn kiểu là à reflection
đây chọn chọn cái hiệu ứng chúng ta quan
sát trên cái hình nha đy ra chuột và
quan sát trên hình
đây thì chúng ta cần định dạng hiệu ứng
nào thì chúng ta chọn hiệu ứng đấy thôi
rồi nhấp chuột vào nha nhấp đây chúng ta
có được cái hiệu ứng m bóng độ m ở phía
dưới này Đấy Đó là định dạng picture
effect định dạng tiếp theo là chúng ta
sẽ là thay đổi độ sáng và màu sắc cho
hình ví dụ đây chọn cái hình
này chúng ta vào piure format có cái
lệnh này đây giống như mặt trời này đó
như vậy cho dễ quan sát à Thay đổi cái
độ sáng của hình này đây
đó thay đổi độ sáng
r tiếp theo là đổi màu thì chúng ta chọn
color
đây màu được chưa À đó là thao tác thay
đổi độ sáng và cái màu sắc cho hình
chúng ta vào mục là correction và color
tiếp tục là chúng ta có thể xóa cái
background cho cái cái hình background
Tức là cái nền ví dụ th chọn cái hình
này nha n vào picture format và chúng ta
chọn remove background nhấp
đây và lúc này những cái cái màu tím tím
tím này này là cái background của
nó nha màu tím tím này là background còn
lại nó giữ lại các cái đối tượng cái ảnh
thực sự của nó này đây thì cái việc loại
bỏ background này có thể Đôi lúc nó
chính xác trường hợp chúng ta chọn
remove background xong rồi chúng ta thấy
như vậy là được Ok thì chúng ta sẽ thực
hiện là
à chúng ta nhắp chuột ở ngoài văn bản để
kết thúc còn không Chúng ta sẽ chọn mụ
disc or change tức là loại bỏ cái cái
cái thay đổi vừa thực hiện đi nha có hai
thao tác là kit chain tức là giữ lại còn
thao tác thứ hai là đ bỏ đi bây giờ ví
dụ Chúng ta muốn giữ lại chúng ta nhắp
chuột vào ở vị trí ở bất kỳ trong văn
bản được chúng ta chọn kip change cũng
được nha đây thì cái hình nó nó chỉ còn
lại như này
thôi đó là loại bỏ background và lưu ý
các bạn rằng cái thao tác loại bỏ
background này không phải lúc nào nó
cũng chính xác và nó theo ý của chúng ta
nha Thì nó có cái hạn chế như
thế và bây giờ Đó là các cái thao tác
với đối tượng hình ảnh Đây là các cái
thao tác cơ bản thôi trong còn trong quá
trình chúng ta thao tác văn bản có một V
ngài các cái nội dung mà chúng ta cần
phải thực hiện nữa những cái video sau
mình sẽ bổ sung những cái thao tác đấy
Vâng Xin chào các bạn